as kovan washes across america
politicians call for new lockdowns
andrew cuomo goes crazy after a reporter
asks him about his state's incoherent
policy
and election chaos 2020 continues i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first i've been telling you for a
long time
you might want to take at least a little
bit of your money and diversify into
gold
silver some sort of precious metal why
because it hedges against inflation and
uncertainty
if you listen to me years ago you would
be a lot wealthier right now because
there is a lot of uncertainty
this year i'm telling you right now you
still have to diversify
this hedges against bad decisions by
politicians and inflation based on
blowing the spending out the wazoo where
should you go to buy your precious
metals you should go to my friends at
birch gold group those are the people i
trust this month they're going to give
you an extra bonus for black friday
through november 27th for every 5 000
purchased birch gold will send you a
free silver american eagle and there's
no limit on the amount of free silver
you can receive that's a great way to
teach your kids the importance of
diversification to qualify when you text
ben to 47
4747 just tell the birch gold
representative about this
offer even if you are investing in a
precious metals ira you still get the
physical silver delivered to your door
which is pretty awesome text ben 247
get a free information kit on
diversifying into gold and then call
birch gold they have an a plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless five-star reviews ask all of
your questions get all of your answers
and then think about diversifying
because everybody should be at least a
little bit diversified text ben
247 47 47 to open that precious metals
ira
and get your free silver before november
27th
alrighty so we begin this morning with
the news
that now in wayne county we have more
chaos more election
chaos so you'll recall to recap our
dramatic
story on tuesday night the wayne county
michigan board of canvassers voted 2-2
they deadlocked on whether to actually
certify the votes in wayne county that
includes
detroit overall wayne county is like 1.4
million voters
okay and there are two republicans and
two democrats on the commission and the
republicans
were very upset because the poll books
in about 70
of the various absentee counting
precincts were not balanced
well what that means is that you signed
up for the absentee ballot
and then your vote actually was not
tabulated in the same numbers
as you signed the poll books right there
the number of votes recorded in the poll
books at a precinct in match the number
of tabulated votes those precincts so
very often when you go to the precinct
they make you sign into the book and
then you go and you vote if the number
of signatures does not match the number
of votes
then obviously the books are out of
balance right this is what the
republicans
were worried about now the numbers that
the books were out of balance
are not generally huge it's not like
they're out of balance by a thousand two
thousand three thousand votes
in each precinct no they're usually off
like somewhere between one and four
votes
but republicans were very concerned
about this now to be fair there were
exactly the same sorts of problems
in wayne county in 2016. the votes got
certified they had the same problems a
little bit earlier this year because
they had a special election the votes
still got certified
the republicans said they initially
voted against
certifying because they were worried
about these discrepancies
and again it is perfectly fair to audit
the vote and make sure
that everybody who legally voted against
counted and everybody who illegally
voted does not get counted
monica palmer was the republican chair
of the canvassing board she actually
suggested at one point she would have
certified the results if detroit were
excluded
and then of course this prompted
concerns of racism now we don't know how
out of count
the ballots were the the poll the poll
books were they really out of balance in
detroit maybe that's why she mentioned
detroit okay but it didn't matter
everybody came down
on her head and they suggested she was
trying to disenfranchise people in
detroit which is a heavily black city
obviously
she said she initially voted against
certification based on the discrepancies
at various precincts she said i believe
we do not have complete and accurate
information
in the poll books when the po books are
unbalanced precincts can't be used as
part of a recount before the county
board reversed its decision
michigan secretary of state jocelyn
benson issued a statement saying quote
it's common for some precincts in
michigan
and across the country to be out of
balance by a small number of votes
especially when turnout is high
importantly this is not an indication
any votes were improperly cast or
counted
so this could mean theoretically that
you did improperly cast your vote that
you actually signed the poll book and
then you screwed up your ballot
it could mean that between the time you
signed the poll book and the time you
submitted your vote you decide you know
what i'm done with this i
i really don't have time to wait for
this you just take off wayne county's
board of canvassers did not certify
results in 2013
after detroit's mayoral primary because
the write-in votes for mayor mike
dugan hadn't been fully tabulated that
was a little bit different because the
canvassing process was completed
when republicans initially did not vote
to certify this according to cbs
news eventually a deal was cut and there
was a unanimous agreement to certify
those results okay so originally there
was a 2-2 split
then the board reversed itself and the
republicans voted unanimously with the
democrats to certify
the votes from wayne county after a long
and dragged out
listening session where people basically
got up and yelled at the various
members of the canvassing board and told
them that they needed to get on track
and the republicans came well now
the republicans on the wayne county
board of canvassers after having
cast their vote in favor of certifying
the election results now apparently they
want to rescind their votes okay now
that has no legal effect
as far as i'm aware it doesn't mean
there will be lawsuits presumably
because they have now filed affidavits
suggesting that they were pressured into
changing their votes in favor of
certifying the election now
let's make something clear just because
that board of canvassers
the the michigan wayne county board of
canvassers did not vote to certify an
election result
does not mean that the state board of
canvassers would not certify the
election results
or that the republican legislature in
michigan was then going to turn around
and vote in favor of republican electors
for president trump
there's still several steps down the
road if you wish to actually reverse the
results in michigan and again
i i will say that you have to have
outsized evidence of
massive voter fraud in order to make
sense of the
of the path whereby you reverse a 150
000 vote discrepancy in favor of joe
biden
right michigan was not a particularly
close state joe biden in the current
count is up by about 150 000 votes
if you have certain precincts where the
poll books are off by one or four votes
that obviously is not 150 000 votes and
simply wiping millions of votes off
the playing card does not seem to make a
lot of sense in either a
moral or legal sense nonetheless uh if
these
board of canvassers republicans were
pressured into changing their vote
that is a pretty serious allegation an
affidavit signed on wednesday evening
two gop members of the four-member wayne
county board of canvassers allege they
were improperly pressured into
certifying the election and accused
democrats for nagging on a promise to
audit the votes
in detroit so originally it was reported
that the republicans
in exchange for getting a state audit of
the voting in detroit had signed on now
they're saying well
now you guys aren't delivering jonathan
kinloch a democrat and the board's vice
chairman told the post it's too late for
the pair to reverse course as the
certified results have already been sent
to the secretary of state in accordance
with state rules
and then he lashed out at republicans
usa today reporter donovan slack tweeted
out a screenshot of an affidavit from
monica palmer
the republican chair of the committee
stating that based on allegations she
made in the affidavit she wanted to
quote rescind
my prior vote to certify wayne county
elections according to ryan's veteran
over at daily wire
palmer disputed the promises she was
told she received from one of her
democratic
canvas board colleagues mediaite
reported she claims contrary to what she
was told on tuesday
michigan's secretary of state jocelyn
benson has not pledged to conduct an
audit of the county's votes to clear up
the minor clerical errors found
she wrote the wayne county election had
serious laws which deserve investigation
i continue to ask for information to
assist wayne county voters that these
elections were conducted
fairly and accurately despite repeated
requests i have not received the
requisite information and believes in
additional 10 days of canvas by the
state board of canvassers will help
provide
the information necessary which suggests
that she wasn't going to hold out on
certifying the election result forever
she just wanted a little bit longer in
order to certify the election
result also monica palmer and other
republicans
uh they've been claiming that they were
they were abused and berated
by various people into changing their
vote
william hartman is one of the other
canvassers he's the second republican
canvasser
and he apparently also filed an
affidavit it shows that hartman claimed
he was berated faced ridicule and was
accused of being a racist after
initially voting not to certify the
election results
he said late in the evening i was
enticed to agree to certify based on the
promise that a full independent audit
would take place i would not have agreed
to the certification but for the promise
of the audit okay so does that have any
real legal effect it doesn't have any
real legal effect obviously an audit
should take place particularly because
it was
indeed widely reported at the time that
the democrats had agreed to do an audit
if they decided to back off the audit
that is
somewhat suspicious does that mean that
the proper remedy for this is to throw
out the entire state of michigan vote
again over over precincts where the poll
books were out of balance by 5 or 10 or
even 100 votes in a state with 150 000
vote discrepancy doesn't make a lot of
sense you need to clean up the system
and make it better and make it fair and
there should be an audit of that system
these pull books should not be out of
line every four years every two years
every single time they vote
it does provide the the impetus for
voter fraud
to to be a problem right you've seen
this in very very close races in clark
county in nevada there's a race that's
actually going to be re-run because the
margin of error
in that race is like 10 votes and so
there you can certainly see how voter
fraud would change the outcome of the
election
in michigan where you're talking about
150 000 vote discrepancy
even if you're going gonna claim that
the poll books were out of line it's
hard to see how that amounts to 150 000
votes magically appearing
on the other side of the ledger we'll
get to more of this in just a second and
give you status update in these various
states president trump has announced
that his team will be doing some sort of
big press conference
today talking about their path forward
to victory there are still lawsuits that
are outstanding in wisconsin
where the trump team is seeking at least
a partial recount there is a recount
that is going on
in georgia uh it is it is pretty clear
in georgia that the recount is not going
to amount to a trump victory at this
point
uh there have been extra votes that have
been found right there's some
5 000 extra votes that were found most
of them cut in favor of president trump
that's not going to make up the
discrepancy
in the actual current vote tally as
things currently stand so there's gonna
have to be extraneous proof that is
brought the kraken must be released
there needs to be extraneous proof
brought now a voter fraud and voter
irregularities sufficient to overcome
the 12 900 vote gap between joe biden's
count
in georgia as currently constituted and
donald trump's vote in georgia as
currently constituted also there i
haven't heard a lot about any lawsuits
in arizona
uh last time i checked arizona is in joe
biden's column from the votes i haven't
heard about any legal action in arizona
which is a problem for trump because
trump needs to win
presumably georgia and arizona and
either pennsylvania wisconsin or
michigan
in order to win the election so even if
you were able to find the evidence of
voter fraud and voter irregularity and
georgia is sufficient
to set aside the current vote count and
even if you were to do that
in pennsylvania where the discrepancy is
70 000 votes or in michigan where it's
150 000 votes
you still need arizona in order to do in
order to win enough electoral college
votes to to shift the election
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because we're now coming down to
basically crunch time we are down to the
very end of the calendar states are
certifying their votes
as we speak and the legal process is
indeed moving forward in real time so
if as i say yesterday sydney pal the
president's lawyer if you're threatening
to release the kraken stop threatening
and now release it
we'd all like to see the kraken at this
point for a lot of threats about the
kraken
some people think it's loch ness monster
some people think it's real
okay that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what you say on fox news it
matters what you are able to demonstrate
in the court of public opinion and in
the court of law we'll get to that in
just
one second first let us talk about the
fact the best underwear you're ever
going to wear i'm talking about tommy
johns you can shop tommy john's black
friday sale right now and give the gift
of comfort to everyone on your list and
yourself with tommy john's men's
and women's lounge world let me just
tell you everything i have from tommy
john is it's like the most comfortable
stuff ever first of all their underwear
are unbelievably comfortable my wife
also has tommy john
she loves their product i mean they're
just excellent plus their loungewear is
supremely
comfortable it's my sabbath wear when
i'm not in synagogue say goodbye to
those old stained sweatpants tommy john
loungeworth luxuriously soft guaranteed
to fit perfectly
with the same level of comfort and
innovation that goes into everything
tommy john makes plus
tommy john's loungewear pajamas and
underwear come in limited edition sets
perfect for giving
but they sell out quick so go order
right now there is no risk with tommy
john's best pair you'll ever wear or
it's free guarantee
shop tommy john's black friday sale
right now make sure your gifts arrive by
the holidays go to tommyjohn.com
ben for 20 off site wide get 20 off for
a limited time only at tommyjohn.com
again that is tommyjohn.com man you can
see the site
for details tommyjohn.com for 20 off
you're not going to regret it once you
go tommy john you're not going to go
back
tommyjohn.com okay so jim garrity has a
rundown over a national review
of where things currently stand so we
already discussed the situation
in michigan meanwhile in georgia there
were at least
three counties that found additional
votes total floyd county found
a bunch of votes like 2700 votes walton
county
found about 284 votes and uh and then
there was a third county as well
that found like 2 400 votes however
most of the counties have already
completed their accounts and their
accounts do match up
to their original accounts as as of last
night
78 of georgia's 159 counties did finish
their audits and recounts
57 of the counties the manual account
exactly matched the machine count
in 21 other counties they were within
one vote of the initial
count okay so that is going to uh
play out and as i say the notion that
that
because you you found 2 700 votes in one
county this now applies to all counties
that's not correct you have to actually
individually audit each one of these
counties and i'm very much in favor of
the trump team pushing
for full audit of all of these counties
i mean it's a presidential election it
seems like we should double count these
things like
let's just go back and let's check it
again and what's the harm
doesn't seem like there's a big harm
here meanwhile in nevada
the trump campaign and the state
republican party have filed another
lawsuit related to the election they
contend that joe biden's 34 000 vote
lead in the state is based on fraudulent
votes they say trump was victorious
in the election no judge has said any
vote was fraudulent
state officials did reject about 2 200
provisional ballots they were rejected
they were not included
in the count as i mentioned clark county
nevada will have one re-vote for a race
but that is because
there was a 139 ballots that had
discrepancies and the margin in one
county commissioner came down to 10
votes
so the discrepancies were obviously more
than the margin of error
in that race meanwhile up in
pennsylvania the trump team
has basically now announced that they
are not alleging voter fraud in
pennsylvania i mean they said this in
their court filings
okay so that's not me saying that that's
the trump team they're not alleging that
there is voter fraud they're
alleging voter irregularity and
violation
of law sufficient to allow for voter
fraud and then asking that the
remedy be that the entire election in
pennsylvania be set aside
that is a very unlikely legal argument
to win
uh so right now unless trump is able to
come out with
a with a rabbit out of the hat in terms
of voter fraud and voter regularity and
that means like actual
real hard-nosed proof uh then these
states are gonna start certifying and
the deadlines
begin tomorrow and they go extend
through next week
so sydney pal's out of time really
again we've asked her on the show what
is the kraken what does the kraken
constitute
release it and then we will all know
more right no more of this like
either it's there or it's not and let's
see it let's see it now is the time
to show it okay meanwhile obviously
kovid is washing across
the nation we're seeing a massive uptick
in cases
all across the nation and it doesn't
matter if you're in a blue area or if
you're in a red area
and the media are trying to turn this
into a blue versus red thing because
this is their favorite thing
to do right you're starting to see
people like cnn's brianna keeler
she's saying well look at this
disproportionately republicans are the
ones who are getting coveted and then
chuck grassley got covered that means
republicans are bad okay
let me just make something clear covet
is not a moral referendum on people who
get coveted
the democrats paganistic attempt to
paint kovid
as some sort of moral blight
that only affects people who are guilty
of a sin as though this is like a
biblical plague right it's after
moses breaks the tablet and then the
plague is washing through the jewish
people but it's only
taking the people who are worshiping the
golden calf like no that's not how any
of this works
okay kovid is hitting everyone coveted
is hitting italy it is hitting spain it
is hitting great britain it is hitting
sweden it is hitting everyone
everyone is getting hit by coven and by
the way it is not about mass mandates
because germany is getting
walloped right now and germany had a
mass mandate as early as may
okay italy has had mass mandates in
place getting walloped
new york has had mass mandates and now
they're closing down their schools which
we'll get to in a second
it doesn't matter according brianna
keeler the only reason that you would
presumably get coveted in the first
place is because you are morally
benighted
because you are morally bereft this is
the narrative the media are trying to
draw
and it's really gross i mean for a bunch
of people who have suggested that
republicans don't care if people die
it wasn't republicans who were running
ads at the dnc suggesting that you'd
only get coveton die if you voted for
trump
and democrats literally brought forth a
woman in arizona who suggested that her
dad
because he voted for trump and believed
in trump died of covid which is pretty
egregiously immoral here's brianna
keeler making the same case about
republican senators
several senators have tested positive in
recent months disproportionately
republican
and yet this is what dan sullivan says
he says the senate should be showing the
american people that it's still safe to
work
well the senate is showing the american
people something
it's showing us what doctors and medical
experts have been warning us for months
not to do it is a teachable moment
because
it's a cautionary tale okay the senate
is not a cautionary tale
nancy pelosi when she gets up in the
well of the senate and she's 40 feet
from anybody
has been speaking without a mask right
chuck schumer has been speaking
without a mask okay this is it this is
all
nonsense okay no one has an answer for
covet how about a little bit of
epistemic humility here how about like
seriously a little bit of humility about
the fact that nobody has a great
solution for coving except for the
vaccine makers right
as i'm going to tell you about in a
second it turns out that wearing a
surgical mask does not actually protect
you
it may protect other people there's a
good study the only good study
really it's the only controlled study
that has been done about mask wearing
it was done by the danish and what they
found
in the netherlands and what they found
is that in fact wearing a mask
that is not a an n95 does not really
protect you it protects other people
because if you sneeze
and you sneeze into a surgical mask it
has less of a spray but
the surgical mask itself is not going to
protect you if somebody else has been
breathing covered into the air for a
long period of time and yet the implica
a cloth mask same sort of thing and yet
the implication
from brianna killer is that if if
somehow chuck grassley had been wearing
a cloth mask then he'd be totally fine
right now
follow the science means you actually
have to follow the science as we will
see people are not following the science
because
there seems to be a bit of a different
agenda here than the science i've been
in favor of mass going to prevent people
from conveying the
the disease to somebody else for a long
time i've been actually very consistent
on this i said you should wear a mask
when you're iron crowded
listen to the show back in march i said
listen wear a mask when you're in
crowded areas with others and you can't
socially distance
okay but at no point did i suggest that
for example a surgical mask was a
guarantee that you weren't going to get
this thing
or that it was sort of a religious item
that was going to it was like a crucifix
on the wall that protects you against
dracula that is not
the way this this disease works okay
we're going to get to more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about a good night's sleep so uh i was
noticing a few
weeks back that my neck was really
hurting in the morning i was waking up
after sleeping and my neck was really
hurting and my wife said you know my
pillow sent you that pillow you need to
unpack it you need to try it
and i got it out i got my my pillow put
it in the pillow case
my neck has been better ever since i
mean my pillow is just a fantastic
fantastic product their pillows don't go
flat you can wash and dry them as many
times as you want they maintain their
shape best of all they are made
in the usa if you don't have a my pillow
or you know somebody who doesn't
now is the time because for a limited
time mike lindell the inventor of my
pillow
is offering his premium my pillows
that's the one that started it all for
the lowest
price ever you get a queen size premium
my pillow regularly 69.98
for only 29.98 that's a 40 savings kings
are only
five dollars more now is a great time to
buy not only are you getting the lowest
price ever they're the best christmas
gifts ever in fact i got another my
pillow just for my wife 29.98 for a
queen size premium my pillow
buy now and mike will extend his 60 day
money back guarantee to march 1st
20-21 go to mypillow.com click on that
radio listeners square
there you'll find not only this great
offer but also deep discounts on all my
pillow products including
the giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper and my pillow towel sets
or call 800
651 11 use promo code daily wire again
that's 800-651-1148 use promo code
dailywear or
head on over to my pillow and click on
that radio listeners square to get
started okay so
three million people in the united
states according to the new york times
or rather the washington post have
active coronavirus infections and are
potentially contagious
according to a new estimate from
infectious disease experts tracking the
pandemic
that number is significantly larger than
the official case count that is based
solely on those who have solely tested
positive
for the virus right we'll have like
numbers showing 175 000 new cases in a
given day
but there are a lot of people who are
walking around either asymptomatic or
who have not actually been tested as of
yet
the vast and rapidly growing pool of
coronavirus infected people poses a
daunting challenge to governors and
mayors in hard-hit communities who are
trying to arrest the surge in cases
traditional efforts such as testing
isolation of the sick and contact
tracing can be overwhelmed when a virus
spreads at an exponential rate
especially
when large numbers of asymptomatic
people may be walking around without
even knowing they are infectious there's
about one percent
of the population like every school
teacher
in the country or the number of truck
drivers and that is a lot of people who
are walking around
infected with covet and testing and
tracing ain't gonna get it done at this
point
at this point all you can do is use the
same sort of responsible behavior we've
been telling you to engage in since the
beginning
stay away from people who are vulnerable
people who are elderly
socially distant wear a mask when you're
in close contact right that is all you
can do that's it
and those are all the things and yet the
the
implication from people on the left is
that not only do they have a solution
the solution is going to be holistic and
it's going to involve the complete
remaking of society so let's start with
the lockdown policy that is now
being praised by the media so first of
all florida and texas are handling this
right florida and texas are saying you
know what we're not locking down
because lockdowns don't work the who
says that lockdowns don't actually work
they i mean we have found that all the
lockdowns do is they might delay
the spread of the disease for a while
right that's what happened in new york
or massachusetts but then
people are going to go out again and
when they go out again they're going to
infect each other again
and it turns out that the more you tell
people not to associate with others the
less sustainable you make the lockdown
plans
and this is why when you set rules for
your kids you set rules that are doable
you don't set rules that are undoable
because then
then once they break the rule they're
more likely likely to break all the
rules so if you lock everybody down you
say you gotta wear a mask
at all times in your house or out of
your house people are just like you know
what i'm not doing any of that
if you tell people look you can go out
and go to work
and go to restaurants eat outdoors eat
in a restaurant with
50 capacity stay six feet away from
other people
and wear a mask when you can that that
is a lot more doable and a lot more
realistic
about keeping a society open and people
living their lives then we're just going
to lock down everything and close all
the schools willy-nilly and all this
kind of crap
so texas and florida have announced
they're not going to be going into any
more lockdowns the news comes as 45 out
of 50 states have seen
at least a 10 increase in coveted cases
from the previous week this is according
to ryan's vedra at daily wire
texas governor greg abbott said in an
interview there won't be any more
lockdowns in the state
he wants to focus on working to heal
those who have coveted so they can leave
the hospitals and get back to their
normal routines
a spokesperson for the governor told nbc
news abbott's plan to slow the spread of
the virus will rely on the data-driven
hospitalization metrics used by doctors
and medical experts
renee ezzy is a spokesperson for
abbott's office they said as some
communities experience a rise in
hospitalizations
the state of texas is working closely
with local officials to quickly provide
the resources needed
to address these spikes and keep texans
safe the state's coordination efforts go
hand in hand with enforcing the existing
protocols
a strategy that proved effective in
slowing the spread over the summer and
containing covet 19 while allowing
businesses to safely operate
the protocols work but only if they're
enforced the reality is that covet 19
still exists in texas and across the
globe
texans should continue to take this
virus seriously and do their part by
social distancing washing their hands
and wearing a mask
these best practices coupled with the
governor's metrics to monitor cover 19
hospitalizations and local enforcement
of protocols are key to mitigating the
virus
and keeping communities and our people
safe florida governor ron desantis also
dismissed the idea of locking down
he said today we are back down to 4 500
cases and a 7.3
positivity rate we believe yesterday's
high number was due to a large
submission file and skewed the numbers
for the day the governor
will not lock down and hurt families who
can't afford a shelter in place for six
weeks especially not for a virus that
has a 99.8
survival rate i know it whenever you
mention this people on the left go nuts
if you mention the survival rate of
covert the survival rate of coven
is 99.8 like for the entire population
meaning like from the time you were born
until the time you die at
in the united states around the age of
82. the fact is that if you are
between the ages of 50 and 70 the
survival rate
is like 99.5
if you are above the age of 70 then the
survival rate goes down to about 94.6
percent
if you're below the age of 20 your
survival rate is basically the whole
thing right no
virtually nobody dies under the age of
20 from covid19
so it's funny we are treating this thing
like the bubonic plague we're saying
it's not like the flu it isn't like the
flu
it's more deadly than the flu by
probably a factor of two or maybe a
factor of three
is more deadly than the flu it is it is
more transmissible than the flu like
much more easily transmissible than the
flu which is why so many people are
getting it and getting it easily
okay all of that is true it is not like
the flu it is also not like the bubonic
plague
okay it is not killing one third of the
population or one half of the population
it's not the black plague it's not the
black death okay if you get coveted
the chances that you survive are
extremely high unless you have a very
significant
underlying condition okay that happens
to be the
reality of the situation and i'm not
basing that on anecdotal evidence i'm
basing that on data
i mean i could base it on anecdotal
evidence i know a bevy of people who
have had it and recovered and been just
fine
okay but it is worthy of note that
nobody in the media
ever like there should be they have the
running ticker on the screen of how many
people have died from covet
they should have permanently on the
screen at cnn fox news msnbc they should
have permanently on the screen when they
discuss covet the differential rates of
death for age groups
they should because that is much more
vital information to you than how many
raw numbers of people
have died of a particular disease right
if you saw
the number of people who die every year
from for example drowning and they just
had a scrolling ticker showing the
number of people who died from downing
you think wow that's kind of a shocking
number of people like i can't believe
that many people drown in the united
states now
swimming must be incredibly dangerous
okay but if you show the rate of death
of drowning in the united states
for various age groups you'd be like
well i guess i could probably take my
kids swimming okay this does not mean
you should be happy to get covered
it doesn't mean that you should be out
seeking covet it does mean that we
should be using
our brains in order to differentially
assess risk based on our circumstances
that would be the rational way of going
about policymaking but we don't do
rational policy making here
in the united states instead we do just
insane
kermit the frog running around with our
hands in the air and screaming miss
piggy
stuff okay we're going to get to that in
a second because that really does sum up
a lot of democratic policy on covet
we'll get to that momentarily first
let us talk about life insurance so the
reality is if you're a responsible
person
you want to make sure that god forbid
something happens to you your family is
taken care of
financially and this is why you need to
go shopping for life insurance you need
to get the life insurance but
you can't really do it well by word of
mouth because how do you know you're
getting the best deal this is where
policy genius comes in
policy genius combines a cutting edge
insurance marketplace with help from
licensed experts to save you time and
save you money
right now you could say 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance when you're shopping for a
policy that could last for more than a
decade the savings really do start to
add up here's how it works first head on
over to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape the best
part they work for you not the insurance
company so if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process
they will take care of everything for
you that kind of service has earned
policy genius a five-star rating across
over 1600 reviews on trustpilot
as well as google so if you need life
insurance head to policygenius.com right
now to get started you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes policy
genius when it comes to insurance
it is nice and quite important to get it
right okay so
over in new york this is how democratic
policy is now being made
they're just shutting down the schools
and this is idiotic policy
i mean full full stop idiotic policy
according to rebecca jarvis
who is a reporter over at abc biz she
reported that new york public schools
have tested more than 140 000 students
and staff
they have a positivity rate of 0.23
percent as of monday 0.23
okay which is like not a high percentage
okay we were told that if new york city
hit three percent they would shut down
the schools but what if
again differential circumstances have
differential rates of positivity
what if bars are significantly more
dangerous than schools for people under
the age of 10
which we know happens to be the case
this happens to be the truth
so new york public schools are going to
shut down anyway yesterday bill de
blasio came out
and he was like yeah you know we
understand that this is bad science but
i guess we're just going to do it anyway
now let's be clear about this there's
only one reason they're doing this
it has nothing to do with the safety of
the kids it has nothing to do with the
safety of the teachers
there there's yet to be to my knowledge
a single instance in the united states
if somebody can fill this in for me i'm
happy to i'm happy to correct the record
there's not a single instance in the
united states
that has been reported of a teacher
obtaining a
obtaining covet 19 from a student under
the age of 10 and then dying from it
not one zero zero and they're shutting
down schools
across blue areas for kids under the age
of ten which of course
makes transmission significantly more
likely because now you're sending all
those kids back home where do you think
most of the disease is being transmitted
it is in close quarters
in homes right that is what is happening
and in intergenerational situations
because what happens when mom and dad
have to go to work well now
seven-year-old billy is in the house
with grandma
and now you have intergenerational
transmission happening well done new
york it's like the stupidest thing in
the world they're hurting the kids
they're hurting the parents they're
hurting the grandparents and they're
doing it really
only one reason why because the teachers
unions run new york the teachers unions
do not give two dams about the kids
they're not a union for the kids
they're not a union for the taxpayers
they're a union that gets the most that
they can for the least possible work out
of the teachers this goes back years and
years and years and years teachers
unions
are some of the worst institutions in
american society not teachers teachers
are wonderful teachers do incredible
work they want to help kids teachers
unions are garbage teachers unions
stump against the interest of taxpayers
they stump against the interests of
students
it's how you ended up with rubber rooms
in new york or people who couldn't be
laid off because
they were still in the investigatory
phase thanks to union contracts of
having abused kids or something they're
put in a rubber room and paid full
salary
on the taxpayer time teachers unions
undermined the ability
of kids to learn and now they undermine
the abilities of schools to stay open
and everybody on the left knows this
but guess who joe biden is talking about
appointing his department of education
all the heads of the teachers unions
the democratic party is run on education
issues by the teachers unions they do
not care about the students they do i
mean
i rarely say that they don't care i
rarely imply that people don't care
about x but it is very clear that the
democratic party cares more about the
support they get from the teachers
unions who funnel tons of money into
their coffers than they do about the
interests of students that is the only
reason you shut down schools in new york
right now
that is the only reason here was bill de
blasio saying nobody's happy about
shutting down the schools that's a lie
the teachers unions are super happy
the teachers unions are very clearly
happy about shutting down the schools
they've been stumping for it despite all
evidence to the contrary for months at
this point
no one is happy about this decision we
all
in fact are feeling very sad about this
decision because
so much good work has been put into
keeping the schools
opened and opening them up to begin with
let's start there opening the schools
when almost no other major school system
in america open making them so safe
but we set a very clear standard and we
need to stick to that standard
okay so he he's saying pretty openly we
set a standard and sure our standard is
moronic but we're sticking to the
standard why
because the teachers unions are making
too much of a fuss and they're making my
life too much of a bother this is what
happens when you have a one-party city
in new york
new york is there is no republican party
to speak of in new york right now it is
just a democrat run city which means
it's a teacher's union run city
everybody knows this
everyone okay it's not even it's not
even a secret it is an open it is an
open
fact of the matter and nobody's willing
to rip on the teachers unions because
they're afraid they're going to offend a
constituency
it's absolutely unbelievable by the way
new york governor
andrew cuomo remember that guy just
wrote a book about how well he handled
global 19 remember that
he wrote a whole book about american
crisis or he had a ghostwriter do it for
him and then he
ran around on tv traipsing around on tv
talking about what a wonderful job he
did handling covet even though his
covet curve looked exactly like the bad
curve in the bad versus good
curve and this is the who is
appearing with his brother on national
tv every night to do a comedy bit where
his brother
showed up with a giant q-tip to talk
about the size of his nose
this guy was hero of the republic andrew
cuomo while tens of thousands of people
died in his state
as he was shipping the olds back into
the nursing homes with kovid
hey so here is andrew cuomo having have
after having
precipitously and preemptively written a
book about how wonderfully he did with
covet
announcing astronomical increases
happening in new york state
western new york worst situation in the
state of new york in western new york
these are the highest rates
9.7 9.4 7.5 7.3 6.8
dramatically higher than anywhere else
it's those areas which are
astronomical compared to
the rest of the state okay you know
which part is not astronomical the
schools the schools are not astronomical
he's talking about rates of seven eight
nine percent
in these particular areas again new york
city public schools point two three
percent positivity rate
again they're shutting down the schools
also just worthy of note andrew cuomo
has blamed every single thing
in the universe except for himself for
his bad handling of covet
all the things right he's blamed he's
blamed president trump he has blamed god
he has blamed republicans he has blamed
the press he's blamed everybody well all
this came to a head yesterday
when a wall street journal reporter
asked him about the school closures and
cuomo was not up on the news
right so cuomo immediately started
firing back by suggesting the schools
were not closed and he didn't know what
he was talking about and the wall street
journal reporter was like well i feel
like parents are kind of confused
because
you're saying one thing and de blasio's
saying another here's andrew cuomo
engaged in
a vicious attack on the press if trump
had done this this would have been the
story for the next
48 hours minimum andrew cuomo abuses a
member of the press by suggesting
that uh that member of the press is
confused and terrible for asking a very
straightforward question
the answer is this state is run like
crap okay it is wrong andrew cuomo is a
bad governor he's a bad governor and
bill de blasio is a bad mayor and
everybody knows it here is andrew cuomo
going nuts on a member of the press
what are you talking about you're now
going to override
we did it already that's the law an
orange zone in a red zone follow the
facts
still confused well then you're confused
i'm confused
still parents are still confused as well
they're schools they're not
you're confused no i think parents are
confused as well
read the law and you won't be confused
okay but
we're confused because what the law says
is that if you get above a certain
positivity rate the schools can be shut
down but new york city
and new york state were reporting
different rates of positivity for new
york city
andrew cuomo is confused because he has
been in this running gun battle with
bill de blasio the two hate each other
it's been this ridiculous mutton jeff
routine
for a while here it's it's absurd it's
absurd but don't worry
these are the people who are following
the signs they know what to do rhonda
santos and greg abbott they're the bad
ones
but andrew cuomo hero of the republic
bill de blasio handling this thing like
a champ while he's out there rallying
for joe biden
and having people paint murals on fifth
avenue in the middle of a pandemic
slow clap for the science right there a
lot a lot of science following i am
seeing
right there okay we're gonna get to
california in a second another great
example of excellent governance
and then we're gonna get to what is the
broader agenda for a lot of the folks
who are now making
policy because it turns out that some of
them are pretty openly talking about
what the broader agenda is for policy
making
during the covet period first let's talk
about a great gift that you can get for
somebody
these holidays and this is a gift that's
going to serve you all year long i'm
talking about raycon wireless earbuds
we've got seamless bluetooth pairing a
comfortable noise isolating fit
you can start listening right away and
you can keep listening for hours the
audio quality is amazing it's comparable
to what you get from other premium
brands except raycon start at half the
price
so this holiday season get them
something they can use for calls or
music for work or play at home or on the
go or pick up a pair for yourself trust
me you are going to be using them
every day one of the things i love about
my raycons they fit my ear absolutely
perfectly
unlike other one size fits all options
these ones have a variety of fits you
can actually customize them to fit your
ear properly go to
recon dot com slash ben today to unlock
exclusive deals up to 20
off your raycon order hurry the offer is
available only for a limited time
you don't want to miss it head on over
to buy recon dot com slash pen to unlock
20 off your recons by recon dot
slash pen they you can use them for
jogging you can use them for listening
to media you can use them for phone
calls
they're great they really are and
they're not going to cost you a fortune
like the other options and they fit
you're better than the other options go
to byracon.com that is b-y-r-a-y-c-o-n
dot com
slash ben to unlock up to 20 percent off
okay in just a second we'll get to
california's
policies and then we'll get to the
overall agenda here because it seems
like there is
a bit of an overall agenda that is now
being promoted
first if you weren't already disgusted
by the legacy media you should be they
lie about everything
they lie about the the dangerousness of
covet by suggesting that it is
essentially the black death they suggest
it's all trump's fault but andrew cuomo
is really good at his job they suggested
that donald trump
is actually the devil like that's just
plain objective reporting he's the devil
and his supporters are racist but
joe biden and kamal harris they're the
best america has to offer if you are
sick
sick and tired of the establishment
media feeding you bullcrap narratives
it's time to replace your cable and your
new subscriptions with daily wire
we have huge plans for the next four
years we are going to replace the media
with your help it starts today candice
owens is joining us over at daily wire
she'll be launching a brand new show
with us early next year
we're also going to be launching an
entertainment channel a new
investigative journalism team and
building partnerships with like-minded
content creators like prageru their
entire show library is now available at
dailywire.com
by the end of the year we're going to be
going after the legacy media we're going
to do it by building a huge
membership base of supporters like you
we need your help to replace the garbage
media that have been spoon feeding you
falsity for decades on end right now
just to show you how serious we are we
are offering 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe tomorrow is the last day you
can get this deal sign up while you can
members got our articles ad free access
to all of our live broadcasts and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show
exclusive readers past content available
only to daily wire members
if you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for live stream
discussions with our hosts and an
amazing online community you also get
not one but
two leftist years tumblers with your
membership as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products so remember that is 25
off all memberships with code election
over at dailywire.com
subscribe replace the legacy media with
us over here at daily wire you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so in california they're also
pursuing bad
policy so the the california policy is
now that you have to mask up outside
your home under a new expanded mandate
according to yahoo news california
health officials issued a new mandate
this week requiring residents to wear
face coverings whenever they are outside
their homes
with few exceptions the expanded order
announced monday means californians must
mask up unless they are alone in a car
or only with those in their household
working alone in an office or room
outdoors and staying at least six feet
away from others not in their household
are obtaining a service involving their
nose or face
or actively eating or drinking so long
as they maintain a physical distance the
new mandate exempts those younger than
two
younger than two yeah good luck with my
four-year-old son yeah i'm
i'm sorry these masked mandates they are
they are ins
they are actually a mask for not really
having an answer to all of this
the truth is mass squaring rates in
major cities i was in la until very
recently
everybody's wearing a mask anyway the
mask mandate is not going to change
anything it is not as though a bunch of
people who are not wearing masks are
going to go oh well now i'm afraid the
cops are going to break down the door
and cite me a hundred dollar fine okay
that
whoever is wearing a mask is wearing a
mask whoever is not is not there was a
previous order in earlier mask mandate
since june
that previous order required
californians to wear face coverings in
specified settings
like shopping taking public transit or
seeking medical care
they still have not said how the new
guidance will be enforced some cities
threatened of sight or fine face
covering scoff laws many law enforcement
agencies said they would instead focus
on educating people
not wearing masks okay now the reality
is again
i'm in favor of mass scoring in close
quarters i'm not anti-mass scoring but
mass mandates have not proved to be a
in any way a problem solver for a wide
variety of countries
germany has a mass mandate italy has a
mass mandate
there are mass mandates all over the
world okay and in many countries with
the mass mandate you can see the charts
the mask
the rates of covet are here there's a
mass man that goes into place here goes
like this for a while and boop
it just spikes during the winter just
like a second wave
right and here's the reality about
wearing masks
mask wearing is good for protecting
other people apparently apparently this
is what we are told
okay we have not a lot of evidence to
disprove that at this point but
it is not true that wearing a mask is
likely to protect you unless you are
wearing like the finest highest grade
caliber of medical mask
this is not according to me this is
according to the new york times okay so
before the new york times checks me for
reading the new york times this is a new
york times story
okay gina colada writing researchers in
denmark reported on wednesday
that surgical masks did not protect the
wearer against infection with the
coronavirus in a large randomized
clinical trial
the findings conflicts with those from a
number of other studies experts said and
is not likely to alter public health
recommendations in the united states now
when they say there are a number of
other studies no
what the other studies show is they take
a mask and then they take an aerosol and
they spray the aerosol at the mask
okay which is not useful this is like
saying that you did a study in ideal
conditions
in ideal conditions and the mask was
somewhat more protective than if you
were not wearing a mask
well guess what life is not in ideal
conditions there's a famous joke
about economists right that economists
live in sort of a fantasy world
of people who don't really exist where
you have two economists
on a desert island and they're trying to
figure out how to get off the desert
island
and one economist turns to the other
economist and says assume a boat
right because they live in a world of
theoretical construct
okay when it comes to mask wearing it is
a theoretical construct that everyone is
going to properly fit a mask to their
face and wear it properly they actually
have courses in medical school for how
to properly don
personal protective equipment random joe
over here who just picked up
a cloth face mask from a street corner
by the gas station
the chances that he was properly donning
his mask and treating it well are very
very low okay so what does that mean
doesn't mean you shouldn't wear a mask
in close contact you should because
again if you sneeze
and you're wearing a mask as logic would
suggest
your sneeze is at least somewhat more
contained than it would be if you're not
wearing a mask
however the evidence suggests that for
the vast majority of people meaning
nearly everybody
who is wearing the same mask all day
putting it in their pocket taking it out
putting it back on their face
messing around with their mask that the
chances that you're going to be
prevented from getting covid by wearing
a mask that is not a
that is not an n95 are actually quite
low the study is published in the annals
of internal medicine
it did not contradict growing evidence
that mass can prevent transmission of
the virus from the wearer to others
but the conclusion is at odds with the
view that masks also protect the wearers
a position endorsed just last week by
the cdc
critics were quick to note the study's
limitations you see how the new york
times is desperately trying to spin away
from this study
it is the only mass study done in real
world conditions and they're trying to
spin away from the conclusions
critics were quick to note the study's
limitations among them the design
depended heavily on participants
reporting their own test results and
behavior
at a time when both mass scoring and
infection were rare in denmark so in
other words we're not going to trust the
study
because some people may have lied about
how often they were wearing masks what
do you think happens in real life
do you think people always tell the
truth or do you think what do you think
is more likely to be an accurate study
of human behavior
an actual study of human behavior or you
take a mask in a in a lab and then you
fire aerosol spray at it
dr anthony fauci of the nia id
advocates a national mass mandate as now
does joe biden
from early april to early june
researchers at the university of
copenhagen recruited 6 000 participants
who'd been tested beforehand to make
sure they didn't have covet
half were given surgical masks and told
to wear them when leaving their homes
others were told not to wear masks in
public
about 4 800 participants completed the
study the researchers had hoped that
masks would cut the infection rate by
half among wearers instead
42 people in the masking group about 1.8
percent got infected
compared with 53 in the unmasked group
or about 2.1 percent
that difference is not statistically
significant dr medicalgar a professor of
medical decision making at university of
oslo says the study showed although
there might be a symbolic effect
the effect of wearing a mask does not
substantially reduce risk for wearers
okay that is obviously
a a problematic outcome for people who
are insisting that you have to wear a
mask to protect yourself
again you want to say you have to wear a
mask in close quarters to protect other
people that's okay but let's not
overestimate what it is the masks do
especially because again we're seeing
spikes
nearly everywhere and there's this
baseline assumption by people on the
left that fulfill
their sort of quasi-paganistic mandates
to do x y or z you won't get covered and
that just isn't true i know a lot of
people who mask up regularly and many of
them have gotten covered
okay that is it covid is easy to obtain
and it doesn't take but one moment
of you removing your mask or of you
breathing
in through a mask in an area that has
already been contaminated
to put you in a bad position so try to
stay outdoors
if you can okay so this does bring up a
bigger question
why is it that so many members of the
left are talking
about you know these sorts of things
while not even following the rules
themselves
right we now know that in california a
state that is mandating mass squaring
nearly everywhere
right really everywhere we now know that
not only did gavin newsom the governor
go to an opulent birthday dinner at the
french laundry restaurant he was joined
by officials from the california medical
association so
let me ask you this do you think that
the officials at the california medical
association
do you think those people were there
because they thought it was wildly
unsafe
or do you think they were using the sort
of differential risk assessment they
deny to you
you're too stupid to determine when you
can be in contact with other people
you're too stupid to determine whether
you can have a thanksgiving family
dinner with a bunch of people under 30
you are too stupid to actually determine
the course of your own life
the folks at the california medical
association will tell you when you can
and cannot meet with people
and get together and go to work but they
themselves will go to a restaurant
and eat in close proximity indoors with
gavin newsom
yes i definitely trust these people to
set the standards there's no hypocrisy
here
whatsoever i'm sorry but the
the idea that the folks and blue states
know what they're doing and the folks in
red states just don't know what they're
doing
there's no evidence that this is the
case like whatsoever it doesn't matter
that's the narrative joe biden is
pushing remember that time
where in an open debate he said that
he's not going to break down
coveted cases into red states and blue
states but red states are getting
especially hit hard because they're bad
he said that in debate with president
trump now he's pushing that even more
yesterday according to the washington
post an emotional president-elect
joe biden praised republican governors
and others who have bucked president
trump to endorse more stringent measures
to control the spread of the coronavirus
while warning wednesday that a tough guy
approach contributes to preventable
deaths
biden contrasted restrictions imposed by
ohio governor mike dewine and a growing
number of other republican leaders with
what he suggested is trumpian at
negligence
he says now you have the governor of
north dakota you have others figuring
out this is real
we've got to do something okay do
something is not an actual course of
action
i understand that it might be the
democrat slogan democrats 2020
do something it depends what the
something is and whether it is well
calibrated to achieve the effect that
you seek
he says it's not a political statement
it's not about you know whether you're a
tough guy or not a tough guy it's about
patriotism
if you really care about your country
what you want to do is keep your
neighbors and your family safe
i agree the question is how you keep
your neighbors and your family stay
safe and don't destroy the entire
society around you
because of lockdowns are egregious the
unemployment rate in new york city
before the pandemic was 3.4 percent
today it is in excess of 14 before they
started any of the reopening it was in
excess of 20 percent
tens of thousands of people have left
new york city
left it and most of them are high net
worth individuals who can afford to
leave new york city destroying their tax
base
there are actual consequences to bad
policy and just shouting mask at the sky
does not mean that you are actually
solving all of the problems
now again i'm not saying they shouldn't
wear a mask all i'm saying is that this
this reliance on mask mandates as sort
of the the
be all enzo ignores how human behavior
actually works
i have for the one thousand time i'm
recommending if you're in close contact
with other people you should wear a mask
to protect them not to protect you
because the study show probably won't
protect you unless you know what you're
doing and you've perfectly fitted it to
your face and you're wearing a 95
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't wear
a mask it does mean that having
these jokers who are out there dining
and having congressional
hearings and meetings dictate to you
exactly how you ought to live your life
is un-american
it is un-american that doesn't mean you
can't care for other people you should i
rely on the american people
to actually take care of their own
family members and you should take over
seriously particularly if you're elderly
and if you're vulnerable
but there seems to be something else at
play here something else at play and
that's something else at play
is the maintenance of a myth the myth is
that government can solve all your
problems that the government has answers
to everything
from every economic slowdown to every
life and death circumstances
they don't the government has done
basically one
good thing throughout this entire
process the one good thing the
government did is they developed the
vaccines okay the government worked in
by the way they didn't develop the
vaccines they worked in conjunction with
those big evil pharmaceutical companies
by offering them basically a low
downside risk
in order to develop the vaccines and i
also happen to be of the opinion
that there is a very very solid shot
that these companies have been working
on a vaccine anyway
given the fact that whoever makes the
vaccine was slated to earn more money
than has ever been created in the
history of humanity
nonetheless the narrative continues a
pace and
and of course then you get wolf blitzer
on cnn saying where is trump the same
people who were saying five seconds ago
they don't want president trump on tv
talking about kovid because he's
undermining public confidence and
coveted response
are now saying where is donald trump uh
all of this is play acting k-fobby
nonsense
another 70 000 might die between now and
the inauguration on january
20th uh you know governor kasich uh we
passed this
awful milestone a quarter of a million
american lives lost
the president is nowhere to be seen at
all
it is in a word given what's going on in
our country right now i
i should say uh sort of disgraceful oh
well you know when he was doing daily
press conferences
which was like not that many months ago
you were saying it was disgraceful that
he was doing daily press conferences
so again when it comes to politics and
covid not science income but politics
and covet
it's a nasty combination we all want
fewer people to die from covet we should
all want kids to be able to go to school
because the science suggests the kids
should be in school
we should all want businesses to be open
and we want them to reopen safely by
taking all the measures they could
possibly take
except if you're in the media in which
case apparently all you do is see this
through a political prism where
everything that your allies do is great
and everything that people you don't
like do
is absolutely evil and terrible and no
good and very bad because let's be real
about this job
doesn't have a plan he's never had a
plan andy slavitt
who's one of joe biden's advisors he has
basically said that joe biden's plan
should be to talk a lot about kovid
seriously that's what he writes today he
writes that in usa today this is the
plan this is the big plan
after we hear about captain science
coming in and carrying covert and joe
biden pledged she was going to stop code
ready wasn't going to stop the economy
he wasn't going to stop everything else
he was going to stop covet
joe biden here's his plan he apparently
is going to
just talk about covet and that's going
to solve all the problems biden must
make it a priority to use the bully
pulpit which has been essentially empty
since the crisis has begun to convince
americans why they should wear masks
socially distance and comply with
testing and contact racing
he must focus in particularly on rural
americans who are trump supporters and
are resistant to any public health
measures
oh if joe biden talks to a bunch of
people voted for trump probably that's
going to solve the problem
i'm sorry this is all this is all
silliness okay so meanwhile there's
something else that has been happening
there are a lot of people who are
talking about something called the great
reset okay now the great reset
there's two forms of of talking about
this one is reasonable one is not
one is a sort of conspiracy theory which
says that a bunch of people get behind
a closed door in a smoke-filled room
well a vape-filled room
and then proceed to discuss how to
effectuate a communist takeover evolved
society by using covet as the lever
and then that's a conspiracy theory it's
not real that assumes
here's the thing about conspiracy
theories they all assume that human
beings are competent and good at what
they do
human beings are garbage and really
incompetent in what they do human
all of politics is veep it is never
house of cards nobody ever has in a
ferry's plan
nobody's ever too affectionate and
nobody is ever able to effectuate their
nefarious plan
if you ever think that there is a
smoke-filled room in which a bunch of
people get together
and they effectuate their master plan it
almost never happens
it is very rare right it takes a con a
confluence
of ridiculous circumstances and mistake
making in order for
conspiracies ever to be successful and
this is not a conspiracy theory okay
it's just out there in the open the real
discussion here is how the left uses
circumstances
like covid in order to take more
government power or to reshift
the nature of the conversation
surrounding capitalism towards something
they want
and that's not a conspiracy theory
that's out in the open and they they
have called it the great reset
and it's a bit of gaslighting from the
media to suggest that if you say the
words great reset you're being
conspiratorial when that term originated
with people
on the left particularly at the un
talking about the so-called great reset
they're actual articles written by
people like klaus
like klaus schwab the founder and
executive chairman of the world economic
forum he wrote a piece october 22nd 2020
it is literally called the great reset
okay so
like this is not a myth okay there is a
there's a lot of talk about
people basically using every crisis in
order to effectuate the political agenda
that was
already on the back burner for them
right they already have this political
agenda they want to use this crisis
as a way of wedging that political
agenda through the front door they just
crisco up that door frame
and they shove their political agenda
through a uh a mismatched door frame
right the the agenda is too big for the
doorframe doesn't matter they're going
to shove it through anyway and this is
what has been happening
at least a little bit with kovid an
indicator of this the social justice
warrior contingent
is getting together today which is
really really exciting stuff
uh they have decided that they are going
to be holding a press conference the
squad community activists climate
advocates and members of congress
are rallying at the dnc
washington dc on thursday november 19th
a coalition of community activists
climate advocates and newly elected
members of congress will hold their
rally at the headquarters of the dnc
oh rally i thought that those were not
good it's a pandemic right demanding
bold action to address the coveted
pandemic the economic crisis and
accelerating climate change
the rally will push joe biden to appoint
a corporate free cabinet
and an administration staffed personnel
committed to addressing the climate
threat
as well as following through on promises
made during the campaign to quote build
back better and this is going to include
people like alexander ocasio-cortez
and corey bush who's the newly elected
congresswoman from missouri
and jamal bowman from new york and
rashida talib ilhan omar rokhana monder
jones and senator ed markey so the squad
is growing
and it's actually a fairly large
contingent that is
some seven members of the house and uh
senator ed markey who are now speaking
uh in favor of basically using coven 19
as a
lever for being able to effectuate their
their favorite policy positions so how
radical is the squad well first of all
i mean pretty damn radical we already
know about the honorable
alexander ocasio-cortez d-twitch we
already know about her but
over the course of the last few hours
cory bush
who was a black lives matter activist
elected to congress in a democratic
district
cory bush tweeted out yesterday it's
simple really we want to cancel student
and medical debt because we believe
education and health care are human
rights
right so she just wants to cancel by the
way if you if you just declare something
right and then say there can't be debt
on that basis these are the same people
say housing is a right so we should
cancel all the mortgages
also you use your credit card for food
food is the right so we should cancel
all your credit card debt
and then when we're done with that we
can ensure that nobody ever gets a loan
we can go back to trading with actual
like seashells and stuff it'll be really
great
and there's a radical group of folks
obviously and just as always just as
rahm emanuel suggested
let no good crisis go to waste they're
not going to let a good crisis
go towards justin trudeau handsome
bernie sanders up there in
in canada he suggested just the other
day that covet is an opportunity to
build
back better uh and he used the words
great reset which obviously
set off some of the conspiracy theorists
suggesting these people are all getting
together and coordinating policy
they're not it's just that the left will
never miss an opportunity
to take a bad situation and try to spin
it
into an instrument the blunt force
instrument to ram through their agenda
here's justin trudeau
building back better means getting
support to the most vulnerable
while maintaining our momentum on
reaching the 2030 agenda
for sustainable development and the sdgs
canada is here to listen and to help
this pandemic has provided
an opportunity for a reset this is our
chance to accelerate our pre-pandemic
efforts
to reimagine economic systems that
actually address global challenges like
extreme poverty
inequality and climate change raymond he
sounds like alexander ocasio-cortez
right every bad thing that happens in
the world is an
opportunity to reset capitalism it's not
and it doesn't matter what the crisis is
whatever the crisis is is the thing that
requires me to do this thing i already
wanted to do
right climate change is such an
existential crisis we have to completely
remake the economy
we have to all get rid of airplanes and
we have to kill all the cows and all of
this sort of nonsense and then you know
what covet requires us to do
exactly the same sort of stuff
incredible how this works okay so there
is the far left wing of the
sort of great reset mentality which
suggests that covet is an opportunity
for us to remake capitalism wholesale
then there's the sort of softer great
reset mentality and this is
the stuff by klaus schwab and this is
the attempt
to turn corporations and business and
supposedly capitalistic enterprises into
corporatist enterprises now capitalism
is a system
whereby you as a producer are attempting
to cater to consumers and bring them the
products and services
they desire corporatism is where you
decide what you think the consumer ought
to want and then because the consumer
doesn't want it you get the government
to sponsor it you get the government to
push forward the program
right this is why what people use in
sort of the the
great reset world as the example of
excellent excellent policy
is operational warp speed right they say
government was able to combine with big
business
in order to promote an agenda that was
good not just for shareholders but also
for the world which is why i've pointed
out you know would have been great for
fisher shareholders if they developed
the covered vaccine
and also hadn't had to take any
government money right that also would
have been fine
right it just made their downside risk
less so they didn't have to worry so
much if they didn't develop the vaccine
properly they could sink a lot of money
into the development of the vaccine and
what should be more of a what should be
more of an indicator
of the efficacy of private industries
the fact that government had to and had
to use private industry
to actually make the vaccines if
government were so great at things why
didn't they just develop this thing
within the nia id
they couldn't they didn't have the
capacity because government kind of
sucks at things
government is just a giant gun a giant
gun and a bag of money and that is what
government is okay so
there is this push now to basically
shift corporations
from serving their shareholders to what
they call stakeholder capitalism
stakeholder capitalism is the suggestion
that corporations are supposed to take
into account
not just the needs of consumers and the
desires of consumers and therefore the
desires of the people who hold
stock and shares in their company
companies are supposed to instead take
into account
all of the myriad factors in the
universe this is the beauty of
stakeholder cap
stop caring so much about your
shareholders instead start caring about
everyone else now in order to foster
this particular mentality you have to
create a false dichotomy
that false dichotomy is that if you care
about your shareholders and you want to
make share
and make sure that your shareholders
make money this means you're going to
exploit other people
right you're going to voice costs onto
third parties so the typical example
people like to use
is shareholder capitalism is you pollute
the lake in order to make money
for your for your shareholders but
stakeholder capitalism is you understand
there are people who live
along that lake and you take their
concerns into account too now the reason
this is stupid
is because if you are a company and you
actually pollute the lake there are tort
laws in the united states and everywhere
else and you will be sued into the
ground
so shareholder capitalism is actually
not in favor of you doing things that
are suitable
right it is not in favor of you
quote-unquote defraying costs for the
moment
by blowing up your company two minutes
from now the very concept that
shareholder capitalism and quote-unquote
stakeholder capitalism
are in direct conflict is the idea that
america
and the world generally everybody's a
sucker and all businesses are trying to
do
is scam that is not true if you run a
company you have to think
beyond we run a company here you have to
think beyond the next two minutes
sure you could if you're a scamster then
you could theoretically make a cash grab
you could
and that happens sometimes but to
suggest that is the bulk of the american
economy or the bulk of the global
economy or that economic growth which is
exponential since 1800
and since the rise of the enlightenment
that economic growth is driven
by a bunch of scam artists who are
basically taking short-term interest
over long-term interest it's just a lie
it's not true at all
okay but stakeholder capitalism really
is a way for policymakers to suggest
that corporations should do our dirty
work so that we don't have to do that
dirty work ourselves
right we should get corporations to do
the things we want them to do so
this guy klaus schwab who again writes
about uh he wrote a book called the
great reset
and he is the head of the world economic
forum he he writes in the immediate
months that followed the outbreak of the
covenant 19 pandemic
the world as we knew it was turned
upside down like most people i was
constrained to observing the situation
from inside my home
and the world economic forum's empty
offices and i relied on video calls to
know how others were doing
since those early moments of the crisis
it has been hard to be optimistic about
the prospect of a brighter global future
the only immediate upside perhaps was
the drop in greenhouse gas emissions
which brought slight temporary relief to
the planet's atmosphere
okay like if that's how you see things
that like you know hundreds of thousand
people dying
nobody has a job but hey we brought down
the global gas emissions
good good stuff happening there right
all right okay
it shouldn't have come as a surprise
that many started to wonder says schwab
will governments businesses and other
influential stakeholders truly change
their ways for the better after this or
will we go back to business as usual
so i have a question um did big business
cause the outbreak of covenant 19
or is big business solving the outbreak
of covet 19. did big pharma start this
or was your was government inability to
actually control this thing
part of the problem in the first place
was it a chinese communist
tyranny that released this thing on an
unsuspecting world
responsible for this or is this really
an opportunity to remake capitalism
i feel like these two things are
unrelated and yet for people who are
into the great reset mentality
it's obviously a chance for them to do
all the things they've wanted to do
right now is your opportunity
it's like it's it's like your free day
from
in in some sort of paganistic religions
there is a there's this idea that you
sort of have a free day from
from want worry and uh and and
answerability you can sin at will for
like one day it's like the purge
okay so basically this is that right
covet is an opportunity to do all the
things we've always wanted to do but
couldn't get anybody to agree to in the
first place
looking at the news headlines about
layoffs bankruptcies and the many
mistakes made in the emergency response
to this crisis
anyone may have been inclined to give a
pessimistic answer says klaus schwab
indeed the bad news related to covet 19
came on top of the enormous economic
environmental social and political
challenges we were already facing before
the pandemic okay let me just make clear
the economy in the united states was at
record highs we were lowering greenhouse
gas emissions in the united states
thanks to fracking the environment was
getting better in the united states not
worse
okay like this is just myth-making with
every passing year
these issues as many people have
experienced directly seems to get worse
not better that's just a lie it's not
it's not true
global prosperity has been going up year
on year for decades on end
it is also true there are no easy ways
out of this vicious cycle even though
the mechanisms that to do so lie at our
fingertips says klaus schwab
every day we invent new technologies
that could make our lives better and the
planets health better
free markets trading competition creates
so much wealth that in theory they could
make everyone better off if there was
the will to do so but that is not the
reality we live in today again this is
just myth making
shareholder capitalism right designed at
profit designed
and making sure that people get the
products and services they want need has
made people all over the world wealthier
since 1980 80 of the world has been
lifted from abject poverty
because of all of this because of free
trade and capitalism and all the things
he's saying don't make everybody richer
he says technological advances often
take place in a monopolized economy
and are used to prioritize one company's
profits over societal progress
the same economic system that created so
much prosperity in the golden age of
american capitalism the 50s and 60s
is now creating inequality and climate
change again this is just a lie it's not
true
the economic system of the 50s and 60s
okay it created
prosperity but also europe had been
completely wrecked since the 1940s
because of world war ii
in fact globally much more prosperity
was created from 1980
to 2000 than than was created in the
1950s and 60s
i mean look at the living standards in
the united states look at life
expectancy in the united states
okay but the idea here is that we have
to redo everything so
what should we do we should model
everything on the
operation warp speed covet response
basically where government leverages the
power of the free markets to do things
the government wants
government top down control that's the
answer
that's the answer he says rather than
chasing short-term profits or narrow
self-interest companies could pursue the
well-being of all people in the entire
planet now here's where you get into
really dicey and ugly territory who
decides what the well-being of the
entire planet looks like
seriously they all policy is trade-off
all policy is trade-off
what does the well-being of the entire
who decides who's dictator of the world
who decides what the well-being of the
entire planet looks like
so for example let's say that you have
an economic program that raises
prosperity all around the world but also
increases greenhouse gases what does the
prosperity of the world look like
which one do you pick this is a pretty
serious question because that is the
question of carbon emissions right
carbon is a significantly more powerful
source of energy than any of the
alternatives that have been provided
and if you decide to put heavy
environmental restrictions on the use of
carbon that mostly hurts people at the
bottom end of the economic spectrum but
according to
klaus schwab just like all technocrats
he believes that there is one simple
answer to this question
and that he has it he can dictate what
is best for the world and then companies
should do what klaus schwab wants
this is how you get to stakeholder
capitalism stakeholder capitalism says
that klaus schwab should have something
to say
about companies in which he bears no
risk has no skin in the game
does not bear the downside risk of the
company going broke and putting all of
its employees out of work
now the basic idea of the free market is
mandeville's idea of the bees
is that because there are so many people
who want so many different things
diversity of marketplaces competition
this drives down prices it creates
innovation and it creates better stuff
for everybody but technocrats
intelligent people for all of time have
thought that if they could just grab the
levers of the economy they could do all
the things that they wanted they could
shift shareholder capitalism to
stakeholder capitalism and the only
stakeholder who really matters
is somebody like claus schwab this is
the great reset we are going to redo
everything in the model that i want and
we're going to grab the power of
somebody else
in order to do it he says this does not
require a 180 degree turn
corporations don't have to stop pursuing
profits for their shareholders they only
need to shift to a longer-term
perspective on their organization and
its mission
oh but you know what a corporation needs
you know
what their long-term interest should be
not the person who runs the corporation
and hires people
you know what we here at daily wire need
to think about 10 years from now you do
you don't know anybody who works here
you don't know how the company works
you don't know any of the family members
you don't know our financial situation
but you know what's best for the world
therefore we should think about what
clef schwab wants
he says they should look beyond the next
quarter or fiscal year to the next
decade and generation
some are already doing so building a
virtuous economic system is not a
utopian ideal
most people including business leaders
investors and community leaders have a
similar attitude about their role in the
world
and the lives of others most people want
to do good and believe that doing so
will ultimately benefit everybody
including a company's shareholders but
what's been missing
in recent decades here it is is a clear
compass to guide those in leading
positions in our society
and economy there we go there we go
so he acknowledges people don't want to
actively do bad they actually don't want
to take into account just short-term
interest at the expense of long-term
interest they want to build for the
future
but they need guides wise guides
wise guides like klaus schwab and covet
is an opportunity
for us to leverage those companies into
doing exactly what we want
and now what corporations have been
doing in response to this is they've
been kind of paying lip service to
stakeholder capitalism so they've been
saying
yes yes that's a great idea we will be
more virtuous and we will be more kind
and we will be more generous
just leave us alone just please leave us
alone and government's like oh okay
we'll leave also we need you to do x y
and z
why do you think corporations have been
bullied into wokeness why do you think
they've been bullied
into undermining their fundamental core
tenets because
they've been playing at this game now
just a few months ago was the
anniversary of a very famous essay
by milton friedman talking about
shareholder capitalism and came under
severe fire that essay because how dare
people
pay attention to their shareholders
instead we should pay attention to these
stakeholders
but here's the reality you have the
capacity to answer to your shareholders
and makes you answerable metrics have to
be delivered your shareholders are
thinking long term most people are not
day traders most people invest in a
company because they want
long-term interest in their company to
hold
okay but what these folks want is a
social responsibility answerable to
government actors they want the
government
to run this stuff okay corporatism
is tricky there's a great piece over at
national review back in august by andrew
stutterford
talking about this corporatism where you
have the government basically telling
people what to do
it's tricky he says it has taken
different forms over the years some more
benign than others all of the forms are
based on the belief society should be
organized by and for its principal
interest groups let's call them
stakeholders
intermediated by ultimately subordinated
to the state the individual doesn't get
a look in but to the management of large
corporations it is an opportunity as
well as a threat
because a lot of the power that is taken
from shareholders will end up with those
who
to whom they unwisely entrusted their
funds right so there are a lot of
corporate heads
are very into stakeholder capitalism why
because let's say you run a corporation
unless you're crappy at your job all you
have to do is point to the stakeholders
for your lack of success so let's say
you're an oil company executive
and you've decided that you're going to
waste a bunch of money on windmills your
shareholders might be like that's a
waste of money why would you do that you
say ah
but i'm thinking of people who are not
the shareholders i'm thinking of people
who don't have skin in the game
see the beauty of capitalism the beauty
of markets is that it puts skin in the
game
if you're going to have a say in a
system you're supposed to invest in the
system
what so many people have been declaring
in the great reset is that you ought not
have a stake in the system in order to
be
able to direct how the system works
okay cloud schwab says we remain far
from our goal of achieving a better
global economic system for all
okay again this is a complete misread
you see it on the right as well as the
left this idea that the economic system
can be shaped from without to the
benefit of all
that is not how economic systems work
and whenever you have a top-down
centralized source of all knowledge you
end up with a worse
less effective and more unfair system
than diffuse bases of knowledge that
form a capitalist system
capitalism is about the acknowledgement
that there are many individuals in a
society they are all the best to
understand
they all have the best understanding of
their own particular interests and that
when you aggregate all of those
interests what you end up with is a
better answer
the wisdom of crowds you end up with a
better answer than one guy at the top
who knows
better than everybody else okay but this
is something that
the global elitists do not understand
and do not like
they wish to run this thing they're all
very much in favor of somebody being at
the top so long as the person at the top
is them according to klaus schwab great
reset guy the stakeholder capitalism
metrics are just one of many initiatives
that are needed to get to such an
outcome time is quickly running out
in a world where pessimism is
increasingly the order of the day and
narrow and short-term self-interest is
still alluring
initiatives like these demonstrate a
more inclusive and sustainable model
is possible okay now understand that
that that's that quote-unquote
sustainable
model that stakeholder capitalism model
that's going to bleed over very quickly
into justin trudeau running the show
it's going to bleed over very quickly
into the honorable
alexander ocasio-cortez running the show
because of course
she is the voice of the stakeholders see
government can always claim to be the
voice of the stakeholders because that's
everybody in society
and you vote right but corporations are
by nature
only small entities in a vast sea of
stakeholders and so you're gonna have
more people from outside a corporation
controlling the future of a corporation
than inside
so what is the great reset the great
reset is not some sort of conspiratorial
backroom deal the great reset is just an
attempt by members of the political left
to grab control of things they do not
own
and leverage those things on behalf of
their own interests that's all it is
and they will continue to do this this
will not be the first or last time that
you see the great reset you're going to
see it with regard to climate change
you're going to see it with regard to
covid and you'll see it whenever the
next crisis appears on the horizon and
if there is no crisis they will simply
manufacture the crisis for the future
it is that simple that's what the great
reset is and we should all be afraid of
it because anybody who declares that
they know what's best
for the globe and then tries to grab the
power to effectuate it is somebody who
should scare the living
daylights out of you all right we'll be
here later today for two additional
hours of content
otherwise we will see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matte wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen
you